bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur ft
france selon la direction de la filiale
française du voyagiste allemand le
tribunal administratif a estimé que
l'ensemble des mesures du plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi était suffisante
est ce que vous êtes surpris par cette
décision forcément surpris mais nous
sommes très très très déçus bien entendu
les salariés de thé lui sont en lutte
depuis neuf mois déjà depuis que les
annonces ont été faites
ils sont extrêmement fatigué par cette
lutte et ils ont manifesté ils ont fait
des communiqués de presse ils ont fait
ils se sont fait entendre un incendie
d'un refus d'être licenciés ainsi
presque 600 to pass mixité les 573 qui
serait apte et déjà dans le plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi en nombre de
suppressions d'emplois en fait mais il
ya vingt six autres emplois qui sont sur
la sellette également on construit à 599
quasiment 600 emplois et donc le cso
c'est à dire le comité social et
économique dont le secrétaire d'ailleurs
et à la cgt
effectivement de cse a saisi la justice
d'abord dans un premier temps la cité en
référé et après sa question le fond et
c'est effectivement nous n'avons pas
gagné au tribunal d'administratif de
cergy pontoise et donc des possibilités
d'appel existent mais je ne connais pas
encore la décision du csi nous le temps
qu'ils se réunissent pour voir s'ils
font appel de cette décision
quels aménagements est ce que vous
espériez eh bien les salariés veulent
conserver leur emploi
et pour ceux qui ont acquis la certitude
qu'ils allaient être licenciés mais ils
veulent des possibilités de reclassement
ce qui n'est pas suffisamment prévu dans
le plan actuel donc sur le fond il ya un
problème de se priver de centaines de
salariés qui ne seront plus là lorsque
le secteur du tourisme va redémarrer
dans j'espère la fin de l'année
être contenue dans les campagnes de
vaccination un peu partout dans le monde
et donc ce serait une entreprise démunis
privé de la plupart de ses salariés qui
devra remettre en route le secteur du
voyage mais également s'il ya des
problèmes sur la forme des des
suppressions d'emplois prévues pas assez
de reclassement pas à passer d'une
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
de ces gens là qui se sont investis dans
un métier qu'ils aiment en tant que
voyagistes
alors concernant les catégories
professionnelles qui ont été retenues
dans le plan social le tribunal
administratif a estimé qu'aucune
segmentation artificielle n'avait été
effectué dans le but spécifique de
permettre le licenciement de certains
salariés fin de citation qu'est ce que
vous répondez dans la segmentation ça
c'est vieux comme le capitalisme
vous savez ce que cherche une entreprise
capitaliste ce n'est pas forcément à
voir le chiffre d'affaires le plus
important possible c'est avoir le plus
de profit possible et d'avoir aussi une
valeur boursière la plus importante
possible déjà annoncé des licenciements
ça fait grimper la bourse où ça
l'empêchent de baisser encore
et puis oui choisir segmenté choisir des
segments d'activité qui serait maintenu
et d'autres pas pour accroître la
rentabilité globale ce sont des
techniques
donc je pense que les le cse et les
experts prononcé selon mis en avant
quelques arguments comme quoi il y avait
bien une segmentation de l'activité et
voilà même si le juge n'a pas conclu là
dessus peut-être qu'une procédure en
appel permettra de retrouver la raison
alors c'est tribunal relève encore que
les salariés des agences cd qui ont opté
pour le transfert de leur contrat de
travail sont dans une situation
différente de celle des salariés
bénéficiant du plan de sauvegarde de
l'emploi
là aussi quel est votre regard le rôle
regard on a réglé une phase difficile où
un certain nombre de salariés de toutes
manières après nauche loin d'eux
de bataille effectivement et c'est de
trouver les meilleurs moyens possibles
de conduire de poursuite de leur
carrière d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc moi je veux pas trop entrer dans ce
jeu là un petit peu qui serait une forme
de division des salariés entre eux il
faut qu'ils restent unis avec leurs
syndicats avec leurs c est ce un donc je
le répète le comité social et économique
qui replace les cee historique et donc
je pense que le propos est quand même
plus large
il ya aujourd'hui dans le ballon dans le
secteur aérien
pas mal de gens qui se sont mobilisés un
que ce soit des hôtesses de l'air de
british airways et united airlines pas
plus tard qu'il y a qu une cuillère en
fait le 18 mars il y avait à peu près
2000 salariés qui sont des gens qui
travaillent à roissy qui ont manifesté
un simple attendre ainsi contre les
suppressions d'emplois dans les
différentes entreprises qui travaillent
sur la plate forme aéroportuaire
donc voilà je pense que la question est
beaucoup plus globale que le devenir
quant aux dires des céréales et de thé
hui près pris dans une approche
quasiment individuelle des problèmes
collectifs
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir ce soir benoît martin secrétaire
général de la cgt paris